لشخصية الاستثنائية،
والقائد الكبير في أوروبا،
الذي لم يستطع دخول مدرسة الرسم ليكون رساما،
لكنه رسم قدر ألمانيا بين الكبار،
وجعلها دولة عظيمة،
هو شخصية خلقت جدلا كبيرا،
فكثر معارضوه،
برغم أن أتباعه ومحبوه كثر،
حينها خططوا لاغتياله أكثر من ٤٠ مرة،
فماذا كانت النتيجة؟
(عن محاولات اغتيال هيتلر نتحدث وللقصة بقية)
أدولف هيتلر لم يخلق شخصيته الجدلية
بسبب محرقة الهولوكوست فقط
بل بسبب سياساته أيضا،..
فعندما أحس بعض الألمان بديكتاتورية هيتلر واستبداده،
بدأوا في التفكير حينها كيف التخلص منه
ومن نظامه النازي،
أجمع عندها ٢٠٠ شخص من المعارضين لهيتلر،
وأسسوا شبكة تدعى"فالكيري"،
هذه الشبكة كان الهدف منها عملية اغتيال هيتلر،
وإزالة نظامه،،
وما زاد هذه الشبكة إصرارا،
هو دخول هيتلر في الحرب العالمية الثانية
معتقدين أنه يجر ألمانيا إلى الدمار،،
في ذلك الوقت دبرت الشبكة أكثر من ٤٠ مؤمرة
لاغتيال النازي هيتلر،
لكن الكثير من المعارضين وجدوا أنفسهم
إما مقتولين أو معتقلين،،
فدبروا حينها واحدة من أشهر محاولات اغتيال هيتلر
، ففي منتصف شهر مارس/أذار 1943
الزعيم النازي  هتلر يتعرض  لمحاولة اغتيال
في الطائرة التي يستقلها،
لكنها نجا وبغرابة!!،،
لأن القنبلة التي خبّئت على متن الطائرة
لم تنفجر نتيجة تجمد الفتيل المتفجر بسبب البرد القارس،،
عندها قرر  كريستوف فون غيرسدورف،
البالغ من العمر 37 عامًا،
تفجير نفسه في موكب هتلر في أثناء زيارة لمعرض
كان مخصصا للأسلحة التي استولى عليها الألمان
من السوفيات، وكان غيرسدورف أحد المرافقين المقربين لهيتلر،
فخبأ قنبلتين في جيبه،
وعلى غير عادته ألقى هيتلر خطابا قصيرا هناك
ثم اتجه إلى قاعة المعرض،
وهناك انزوى غيرسدورف في زاوية ليشعل فتيل القنبلتين،
لكنه لم يستطع ألا تجهيز فتيل قنبلة واحدة،
وقرر الاكتفاء بها لأنها ستفي بالغرض،
فسيحتاج إلى ١٠ دقائق
لأن يكون بجانب هيتلر وتنفجر القنبلة به
وبهيتلر وبقادته النازيون،
لكن هيتلر غادر فجأة وعلى غير العادة أيضا،
ونجا مرة أخرى وبغرابة شديدة، ،
وفي يوم 20 يوليو/تموز 1944،
هرّب كلاوس فون شتاو فنبرج  حقيبة متفجرات
داخل اجتماعٍ  الفوهرر لقتله
. ووضع شتاوفنبرج الحقيبة قريبةً من هتلر
خلال الاجتماعٍ العسكري في بولندا الحالية،
ثم غادر الغرفة بادعاء تلقي مكالمة هاتفية.
أصاب الانفجار لاحقاً كاتب الاجتماع و3 ضباط
آخرين بجراح مميتة....
لكن هتلر مرة أخرى خرج سالماً وبأعجوبة،
لأن أحد الضباط المقتولين نقل الحقيبة بعيداً عنه
ليرى بوضوح خريطة على المنضدة،
ما أدى لنجاته، بينما تمزق بناطله نتيجة للانفجار،
وأُصيب بثقبٍ في طبلة الأذن.
أُعدم شتاوفنبرج،
الذي تعرض لخيانة من جانب أحد المخططين الآخرين معه،
الذين وشوا به،
ورغم أن فريق العملية قالوا إن  شتاوفنبرج
لم يكن الشخص المناسب، إلا أن أحداً غيره
لم يمتلك الشجاعة الكافية لتنفيذ العملية.
وتم إعدام شتاوفنبرج في ذلك الوقت،، ،
وفي الأسابيع التالية للعملية،
قتل النازيون جميع المخططين الباقين الـ200 تقريباً،
وكانوا في بعض الحالات يعلقونهم بوحشية كالمصلوبين
فيما يشبه خطافات اللحم....
وهكذا مرت محاولات اغتيال هيتلر،
بين فشلها واكتشافها،
وبين نجاة هيتلر بغرابة،،
لكنه وفي كل الأحوال كان قائدا عظيما محنكا
صنع هالة  من الذعر حوله تربك أي شخص يحاول تدبير
أي شيء من ورائه،،
فهل كانت هذه الشبكة هي الوحيدة التي حاولت
اغتيال الزعيم النازي هيتلر؟...